and i guess chaos in afghanistan
embarrassment on the world stage
americans endangered this is the price
that we pay this is the cost of a
significant percentage of the american
population doubtful many of you watching
but a significant percentage of the
american population voting for someone
but not for someone but voting against
someone no one voted for joe biden
that's just a fact no one showed up to
his socially distanced zoom rallies no
one no one has ever said i love joe
biden
the entire american population either
voted for or against president donald
trump hell no one even vetted joe biden
and now
we pay the price in the form of an
incompetent empty suit who's
and let's be real here physical and
mental condition may not be up to the
job
now that's not to be mean or to have a
hot take this is important because it's
dearly costing the united states of
america it already has cost us countless
trillions it's cost of stature in the
world credibility
and it may soon cost us american lives
this is a big deal and we just simply
can't be nice about it anymore
every week this country seems to be
shoved into another crisis by a
president who doesn't seem to know where
he is
and every time he says things are under
control you can be rest assured the
exact opposite is true
so today when he promised that he's
going to bring every last american
stranded in afghanistan home i'm more
than a little skeptical and when his
plan to get americans scattered
throughout afghanistan back to the
airport revolves around trusting the
taliban
i'm more than concerned
we have no indication that they haven't
been able to get in kabul through the
airport we've made an agreement with the
with the taliban thus far they've
allowed them to go through which in
their interests are going to go through
so we know of no circumstance where
american citizens are carrying an
american passport are trying to get
through to the airport that is contrary
reports that is not true that is a lie
the taliban are calling the shots not
joe biden and getting americans to the
airport isn't as easy as the president
is clearly letting on right there here
for example is one firsthand account of
what's really going on on the ground
trying to get to the airport
when we got there there was a crowd of
several hundred potentially even you
know over a thousand uh individuals i
mean afghans who were desperate to get
into the
into the airport able to make contact
with with one of the marines he was
yelling you know american american
americans here
and he just you know i made eye contact
with him and he just says get out get
back now get back now
and the marines are just you know firing
you know um you know their their weapons
you know firing water shots in the air
that doesn't sound like the taliban
serving as ushers at the airport which
by the way is the one part of
afghanistan that joe biden claims we
have secured and it is totally engulfed
in chaos see for yourself
[Music]
[Music]
and that's what you can look forward to
if you take joe biden's advice if you
can make it through the taliban
checkpoints who apparently will gladly
let americans through without harm
ignore the reports that they are going
house to house hanging people who have
worked with the united states and ignore
the video of the taliban militants
brutally executing an afghan police
chief joe biden seems confident in his
should we call it a plan
or at least he wants us to think he's
confident
this is one of the largest most
difficult airlifts in history
and the only country in the world
capable of projecting this much power
on the far side of the world with this
degree of precision is the united states
of america
is that what we're doing we're
projecting power this is power
france and britain are going in kicking
butt dispatching special forces to
rescue their citizens and this started
last saturday while the pentagon holds
our troops back
meanwhile we don't even know how many
americans are stranded behind enemy
lines
don't have the exact number of people
who are
americans are there and those who may
have come home to the united states
we're not we want to get a strong number
as to exactly how many people are there
how many american citizens and where
they are
does that inspire confidence for anyone
the american people the american
military our allies our adversaries
presidents and presidencies are defined
by how they respond to a crisis the
difference here what we're watching is
is this is a crisis created by a
president and add it to the growing list
of crises facilitated by president joe
biden the border disaster
inflation a nationwide crime spike these
are not crises that he inherited these
are crises that he has created
now many americans i think
are rightly asking themselves if joe
biden is physically and mentally up for
the job but that might not be the real
question the real question might just be
is joe biden the one doing the job hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else